Andy's grandfather ran the business, then his father ran the business. They make mousetraps. Victor brand mousetraps with a big red  V on them. But also glue traps and electric traps and those humane catch-and-release things and traps that only professionals use. Andy's in charge of the part of the company that develops the new products, and the job suits him. I called him in his office.
安迪的祖父经营着这家公司，后来他父亲接手。他们制造捕鼠器。那是维克多（Victor）品牌的捕鼠器，上面印有一个红色的大写字母V。但也生产粘鼠板、电子捕鼠器，以及那些人道的活捉释放装置，还有只有专业人士才会使用的捕鼠器。安迪负责公司的新产品开发部门，这份工作很适合他。我在他的办公室给他打了电话。
I remember coming out here on Saturdays when I was very young and seeing the mousetraps being made and just being intrigued by the business.
我记得我很小的时候，周六会到这里来，看着捕鼠器被制造出来，单纯地对这个行业感到好奇。
So I understand that, because you guys are the number one mousetrap company in the world, people pitch you ideas on how to make a better mousetrap, right?
所以我能理解，因为你们是世界上第一大捕鼠器公司，人们肯定会向你们推销如何制造更好捕鼠器的点子，对吧？
All the time.
一直都有。
Can I ask you to just talk about some ones that were especially bad?
我能请你谈谈其中一些特别糟糕的案例吗？
Oh, my. One that we rejected was one that is basically like a pail that, in essence, the mouse can run up the side of up a stairway and then, between one side of the bucket and the other, there's a dowel. And in the middle of it a little cup of bait. So they run across the dowel and once they get to the cup, it turns over and spills them--
哦，天哪。我们拒绝过一个点子，本质上就像一个水桶，老鼠可以顺着侧面的楼梯跑上去，而在水桶两侧之间有一根横杆。横杆中间放着一个小杯诱饵。当它们跑过横杆，到达杯子所在位置时，它会翻转并把它们倒进去——
Into the bucket.
掉进桶里。
Into a pail of-- and since they wanted to be environmentally friendly, a pail of antifreeze that was environmentally friendly.
掉进一桶——因为他们想做得环保，所以是一桶环保防冻液。
Wait. Wait. What?
等等。等等。什么？
Right, and I believe that the antifreeze would also keep the scent problem down of a dead rodent. You might have a whole 20 drowned mice in this thing. I mean, incredibly ingenious and very clever.
没错，我相信防冻液还能抑制死老鼠的气味。这东西里可能会淹死整整20只老鼠。我的意思是，非常有创意且非常巧妙。
So you think that actually could work?
所以你认为这真的行得通？
Oh, it does work.
哦，它确实行得通。
It does work, but it's not the sort of thing that you think many people are going to want to buy.
它行得通，但这不是那种你认为会有很多人想买的东西。
Right. Right. People really don't want a pail-- to end up with-- I mean, having a dead mouse for a lot of people's a problem. Having a dead mouse in a pail of antifreeze and dumping it out-- or, in this case, having maybe six or seven-- just is not commercially, in our opinion, a great opportunity.
对。对。人们真的不想要一个桶——最后还要处理掉——我的意思是，对很多人来说，拥有一只死老鼠是个问题。在一个装满防冻液的桶里有一只死老鼠，还要把它倒掉——或者在这个案例中，可能有六七只——在我们看来，在商业上并不是一个很好的机会。
I mean, people are incredibly creative. I mean, I've got a book of patents that were just from the late 80s to, like, 1950 and there are thousands and thousands of tanks and cages, all sorts of weird looking shaped boxes and things that look like medieval torture chambers.
我的意思是，人们非常有创造力。我有一本专利书，记录了从80年代末到1950年之间的专利，里面有成千上万个水箱和笼子，各种形状怪异的盒子，看起来就像中世纪的刑具。
Can you tell me one where you totally admired the ingenuity, but you just thought, no way?
你能告诉我一个你非常钦佩其独创性，但又觉得完全行不通的例子吗？
Yeah, I sure will. This one is alarming in its ingenuity. A mouse went into a little box area and when it nibbled at the bait, the door shut behind them. OK, nothing too abnormal about that. But it dropped a pill into a little bit of water and the pellet dropped into water and it gave off a gas that killed them. It would die of carbon monoxide poisoning. In other words, it went into a gas chamber.
可以，我当然可以。这一个的独创性令人震惊。一只老鼠走进一个小盒子里，当它啃食诱饵时，门就在它身后关上了。好吧，这没什么不正常的。但它往一点水里掉了一颗药丸，药丸掉进水里后释放出一种气体把它们杀死了。它会死于一氧化碳中毒。换句话说，它走进了一个毒气室。
And was this ever sold anywhere?
这东西在什么地方卖过吗？
In Germany.
在德国。
Oh, come on.
哦，拜托。
I am not kidding.
我没开玩笑。
I'm sitting here literally stunned. As a Jewish person, I actually am stunned.
我坐在这里简直惊呆了。作为一个犹太人，我真的惊呆了。
I was horrified. We didn't think that had very good commercial viability in the United States. And we were kind of surprised that it was available, that people were trying to market it in Germany.
我感到非常恐怖。我们认为它在美国没有很好的商业可行性。我们很惊讶它竟然能上市，竟然有人试图在德国推销它。
So with all of these people trying to invent a better mousetrap, the dirty secret of trapping mice is mice are really easy to catch. That's why every inventor thinks that he can do it. Catching a mouse is basically playing against a casino where you always win.
那么，随着所有这些人试图发明更好的捕鼠器，捕鼠行业的一个肮脏秘密是，老鼠其实非常容易抓。这就是为什么每个发明家都认为自己能做到。抓老鼠本质上是在和赌场博弈，而且你是稳赢的。
The regular, old-fashioned, cheap, little mousetrap, Andy says, will usually catch the mouse in 24 to 48 hours. It will kill it 88% of the time. Other traps that aren't much more expensive have 100% lethality. Mice are easy to kill because mice, unlike rats, are incredibly inquisitive animals.
安迪说，普通、老式、便宜的小型捕鼠器通常能在24到48小时内抓住老鼠。它有88%的几率将其杀死。其他价格并没有贵多少的捕鼠器则有100%的致死率。老鼠很容易杀死，因为与大鼠不同，老鼠是非常好奇的动物。
They investigate anything that's new, anything that's in their normal territory for the evening. And that's typically-- most people don't know this but most mice only stay within 10 feet of where they are, max. And oftentimes it's less than that. And they may investigate that area 30 times during the night. They're not just kind of going out once.
它们会调查任何新奇的事物，任何晚上出现在它们正常活动区域的东西。而且通常——大多数人不知道这一点，但大多数老鼠的活动范围仅限于离它们所在位置最大10英尺（约3米）的地方。通常甚至不到这个距离。它们可能在一晚上会调查那个区域30次。它们并不是只会出来一次。
Well, in a way, what you're describing is almost the ideal animal to be caught.
好吧，从某种程度上说，你所描述的几乎是理想的被捕捉动物。
Exactly.
完全正确。
So the problem for the mousetrap inventor is the world doesn't need a better mousetrap. You know that old saying, "Build a better mousetrap and the world will beat its way to your door?" Not true. Andy makes a traditional mousetrap that sells two for $0.99. It does the job just fine. But most inventors never understand this.
所以对于捕鼠器发明家来说，问题在于世界并不需要更好的捕鼠器。你知道那句老话吗，“造出更好的捕鼠器，世界就会踏平你的门槛？”这不是真的。安迪制造的传统捕鼠器卖0.99美元两个。它完成工作就很好。但大多数发明家从来都不明白这一点。
Well, they are always persistent. Whether it's letters or phone calls or stopping here, they are passionate about their idea and are so disappointed when we turn them down.
好吧，他们总是很执着。无论是写信、打电话，还是直接到这里来，他们对自己点子的热情不减，当我们拒绝他们时，他们会非常失望。
Like, they can't believe it.
就像，他们无法相信。
They can't believe it.
他们无法相信。
Because for them, there's the magic of the moment of invention, right? Like, they actually came up with a new idea.
因为对他们来说，那一刻有发明的魔力，对吧？就像，他们真的想出了一个新的点子。
That's right.
没错。
And it turns out that's just not enough in this cold, cold world.
但事实证明，在这个冷酷冷酷的世界里，这还不够。
It's very hard. It's their baby. Again, they have nurtured this thing.
这很难。这是他们的心血结晶。再说一次，他们一直像养育孩子一样呵护这个东西。
Well, today on our program, we have four stories of inventions in a world that doesn't always need or want new ideas. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲四个关于发明的实验故事，这个世界并不总是需要或想要新的点子。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（Public Radio International）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
We have four stories of ingenuity and heartbreak for you. Act One of our show today, "Mother of Invention," in which we look at an experimental child rearing technique, whose effectiveness you can judge for yourself. Act Two, "Financial Mousetrap," in which we return to our ongoing coverage of the economic crisis, a place where Wall Street invented all kinds of stuff and it turned out the world would have been better off without a lot of it. Act Three, "Everything Must Go," in which a man tries to solve the problem posed by big plastic bags of US currency. Act Four, "The Not-For-Profit Motive." Our own Alex Blumberg explains what happens when our government has to reinvent itself as a bank, and not necessarily a successful bank. Stay with us.
我们为您准备了四个关于独创性与心碎的故事。我们今天节目的第一幕，“发明之母”，在这一幕中，我们将审视一种实验性的育儿技术，其实际效果您可以自行评判。第二幕，“金融捕鼠器”，我们将回到对经济危机的持续报道，华尔街发明了各种东西，结果证明如果很多东西根本不存在，世界会更好。第三幕，“清仓大甩卖”，讲述一个人试图解决由装满美国货币的大塑料袋所带来的问题。第四幕，“非营利动机”。我们的同事亚历克斯·布隆伯格将解释当我们的政府必须将自己重塑为一家银行，而且不一定是一家成功的银行时，会发生什么。请继续收听。
Act One, "Mother of Invention." So we start with somebody inventing a new way to do something in an area of life where you might not think there could be any new ways to do anything left. Karen Sosnoski tells the story. Her son, Anton, was born with Mosaic Down Syndrome, which is this very rare form of Down Syndrome. Essentially, some of his cells have the extra chromosome that causes Down Syndrome. And the other cells don't.
第一幕，“发明之母”。我们先从某人发明一种新方法来做某事开始，在生活的某个领域，你可能认为已经没有任何新方法可以尝试了。凯伦·索斯诺斯基讲述了这个故事。她的儿子安东患有马赛克型唐氏综合征（Mosaic Down Syndrome），这是唐氏综合征的一种非常罕见的形式。本质上，他的一些细胞带有导致唐氏综合征的多余染色体，而另一些细胞则没有。
So as he grows, he could actually end up having all the health risks and challenges of Down Syndrome, or very few of them. There's no way to know. Some kids with MDS look totally normal, but then have all kinds of learning disabilities. Others have all the physical features of a person with Down Syndrome, but then have a high IQ. It's a diagnosis that's so vague, it can drive a parent crazy. And Karen had no idea what the diagnosis would mean for her son's future.
所以随着他的成长，他最终可能面临唐氏综合征所有的健康风险和挑战，也可能只有很少一部分。没有办法预知。一些患有马赛克型唐氏综合征的孩子看起来完全正常，但却有各种学习障碍。另一些则具有唐氏综合征患者的所有身体特征，但智商却很高。这是一个非常模糊的诊断，足以让父母发疯。凯伦根本不知道这个诊断对她儿子的未来意味着什么。
So she started doing some research. She found a Mosaic Down Syndrome website. And on that website, she started reading about a boy named Tim. A boy who, in a bunch of different ways, was not what she was expecting. And whose mom had invented a radical way of dealing with the diagnosis, something Karen had never heard of. Here she is.
于是她开始做一些研究。她找到了一个马赛克型唐氏综合征的网站。在那个网站上，她开始读到一个叫蒂姆的男孩的故事。一个在很多方面都和她预想的不一样的男孩。他的妈妈发明了一种激进的方法来处理这个诊断，这是凯伦从未听说过的。下面请听她的讲述。
Tim was 13 when I first saw his picture on the Internet. He had geeky, blunt cut bangs and a wide, innocent smile. He had the same diagnosis as my son, Anton, but he had the happy face of an ordinary boy. And when I looked at this photo, my heart raced with hope. Here was a kid I could imagine as my own. a late bloomer, his mom wrote, but so what? He had hobbies and friends. He was a book worm like I am.
当我在互联网上第一次看到蒂姆的照片时，他才13岁。他留着呆呆的、平齐的刘海，露着天真烂漫的笑容。他和我儿子安东的诊断结果一样，但他有着普通男孩快乐的脸庞。当我看到这张照片时，我的心因希望而狂跳。这是一个我可以想象成为我儿子的孩子。他妈妈写道，他是一个大器晚成的人，但那又怎样？他有爱好和朋友。他像我一样是个书虫。
To be honest, Tim's bio made me feel less guilty about Anton. Part of me blamed myself for what had happened. Everyone knew advanced maternal age was a major risk factor for having a baby with Down Syndrome, and here I'd waited until 40 to have him. But maybe if I played my cards absolutely right from here on in, he could still turn out just fine.
老实说，蒂姆的个人简历让我对安东感到没那么内疚了。我的一部分内心责怪自己导致了这一切。每个人都知道高龄产妇生出唐氏综合征婴儿的风险很大，而我等到40岁才生他。但也许如果我从现在起把每一步都走好，他仍然可以成长得很好。
Tim's mother, Kristy, was kind of like a role model for me. She founded an international support group for parents of kids with Mosaic Down Syndrome. She wanted us to be sure the world gave them a fair shake, and I liked this. But to make this happen for her own son, she did something I could never have imagined, something that shocks people every time I tell them.
蒂姆的妈妈克里斯蒂对我来说就像一个榜样。她为马赛克型唐氏综合征儿童的父母建立了一个国际支持小组。她希望我们确保世界能公平地对待他们，我很欣赏这一点。但为了让她自己的儿子实现这一点，她做了一件我无法想象的事，这件事我每次告诉别人时，他们都会感到震惊。
For years, she kept her son's diagnosis a secret. She didn't tell his teachers, she didn't tell her neighbors, and, most incredibly, for the first 14 years of his life, she didn't tell Tim. I first heard Kristy talk about her secret at a conference. Then a couple months ago, I left my one-year-old son Anton for the first time and traveled down to Texas to find out more from Kristy and Tim.
多年来，她一直对儿子的诊断保密。她没有告诉他的老师，没有告诉邻居，最不可思议的是，在他生命的前14年里，她甚至没有告诉蒂姆。我第一次听克里斯蒂谈论她的秘密是在一次会议上。几个月前，我第一次离开我一岁大的儿子安东，前往德克萨斯州，想从克里斯蒂和蒂姆那里了解更多情况。
How had Tim turned out so well? How much of it was because she'd kept his diagnosis a secret? She told me she didn't start off planning to deceive anyone. When Tim started kindergarten, Kristy did what most parents do. She didn't keep his disability a secret. She explained to the teachers that he had Mosaic Down Syndrome, she asked the teachers to treat him like any other kid, and she crossed her fingers. But it didn't work out as she'd planned. This is Kristy.
蒂姆为什么会发展得这么好？其中有多少是因为她对诊断保密？她告诉我，她并没有从一开始就计划欺骗任何人。当蒂姆上幼儿园时，克里斯蒂做了大多数父母会做的事。她没有隐瞒他的残疾。她向老师解释了他患有马赛克型唐氏综合征，她要求老师像对待其他孩子一样对待他，然后她祈祷一切顺利。但结果并不如她所愿。这就是克里斯蒂。
I know one time I went in there to visit the classroom and all the little children are sitting up in their nice little story time circle, and he's laying in the middle of the carpet, rolling around and laying around. And I asked the teacher, I said, why is he laying when everyone else is sitting down? And she said, well, he likes to do that and we just want to make him happy. And so, it was because he had Mosaic Down Syndrome.
记得有一次我进去参观教室，所有的小朋友都坐在他们漂亮的讲故事小圈子里，而他却躺在地毯中间，滚来滚去。我问老师，我说，为什么大家都在坐着的时候他却躺着？她说，哦，他喜欢那样，我们只是想让他开心。所以，这是因为他患有马赛克型唐氏综合征。
And so I knew then, maybe it's not a good idea for everybody to know because they're going to make excuses for him. And I wanted him, more than anything, to just be as normal as normal is, to have the same opportunities that everyone else had. So the next year, when school began, I didn't tell his teacher.
所以我那时就知道，也许不让每个人都知道是个好主意，因为他们会为他找借口。我最希望的就是他能像正常人一样正常，拥有和其他人一样的机会。所以第二年，当学校开学时，我没有告诉他的老师。
And then we thought, you know, if he knows that he has Mosaic Down Syndrome, he's going to use that for a crutch, big time. So we decided, you know, we're just not going to tell him until he gets a little bit older.
然后我们想，你知道，如果他知道自己患有马赛克型唐氏综合征，他会以此为借口，非常严重。所以我们决定，你知道，直到他长大一点，我们都不会告诉他。
Which could get kind of complicated. She had to talk behind Tim's back and over his head. She had to tell family members never to mention Tim's condition in front of him.
这可能会变得有点复杂。她必须在蒂姆背后讨论，还要避开他。她必须告诉家人在蒂姆面前绝口不提他的病情。
And it's OK if you people know it, but I don't want him to know it. I turned into a tricky person.
如果你们这些人知道是可以的，但我不想让他知道。我变成了一个狡猾的人。
Were there times when you were tempted to tell him?
有没有什么时候你想过告诉他？
One time stands out really, really deeply in my mind. He was around 10 years old. And he had a little tree house, and all the kids would come over to be in his tree house with him. And this one little boy in our neighborhood had Down Syndrome.
有一次在我的脑海中印象非常非常深刻。他大约10岁。他有一个小树屋，所有的孩子都会来他的树屋里找他玩。我们社区里有个小男孩患有唐氏综合征。
And I looked outside. All the kids are playing, and Tim pushed this little boy down. And I was, like, no, you don't push him down. That's not nice, you know.
我往外看。所有的孩子都在玩耍，蒂姆把那个小男孩推倒了。我说，不，你不能推倒他。那不礼貌，你知道。
And I made him come inside and  I said, why did you push this little boy down? And he goes, I don't like him. He looks different. That crushed me. That crushed me.
我让他进屋，问他为什么把那个小男孩推倒？他说，我不喜欢他。他看起来不一样。这让我心碎。这让我心碎。
And I said, well, why don't you like him? Just because he looks different? Everybody looks different. And he said, no, he talks funny. I don't like him. And I wanted so much at that point to say, don't you know that you have the same chromosomes as him.
我说，那么，你为什么不喜欢他？仅仅因为他看起来不一样？每个人看起来都不一样。他说，不，他说话怪怪的。我不喜欢他。那一刻我非常想说，你难道不知道你的染色体和他的一样吗。
When I was a lot younger, I used to think that because I was different that made me-- because I was different, I thought maybe I was from another world. That I was an alien or something.
当我年纪小得多的时候，我过去常想，因为我与众不同，所以……因为我与众不同，我想也许我来自另一个世界。我是一个外星人什么的。
This is Tim. He's almost 20 now but he doesn't look much older than his picture at 13. It's not super obvious that he has a medical condition, but if you're at all tuned into Down Syndrome, you could probably guess. His eyes have those extra folds and he talks in a slow, careful way like he's having to work to shape his words.
这是蒂姆。他现在快20岁了，但看起来并不比他13岁时的照片大多少。虽然不是特别明显他患有疾病，但如果你对唐氏综合征有所了解，你可能会猜到。他的眼睛有那种多余的褶皱，他说话的方式很慢、很谨慎，就像他不得不努力去组织词汇一样。
Academically, though, Tim blows any stereotypes about Down Syndrome out of the water. His IQ is 110, higher than the national average. He got A's and B's with no special help at a mainstream school.
不过在学业上，蒂姆打破了任何关于唐氏综合征的刻板印象。他的智商是110，高于全国平均水平。他在主流学校无需特殊帮助就取得了A和B的成绩。
But by junior high, Tim was starting to have a hard time fitting in with other kids. He would do weird things like burp, or rock on his heels in class. He'd say inappropriate things, like the time he got so excited about a slasher movie that he confused himself with the main character. "I started shooting people," he told the kids at his lunch table. As you can imagine, he didn't make a lot of friends this way.
但到了初中，蒂姆开始难以融入其他孩子。他会做一些奇怪的事情，比如打嗝，或者在课堂上前后晃动脚后跟。他会说一些不得体的话，比如有一次他对一部砍杀电影感到太兴奋，以至于把自己和主角弄混了。他在午餐桌上对孩子们说：“我开始杀人了。”你可以想象，他这样是交不到什么朋友的。
All I knew was that I was different because people were bothering me all the time.
我只知道我与众不同，因为人们一直在骚扰我。
Can you give an example?
你能举个例子吗？
Insults, being picked on, teased, hazing, if you know what that is.
侮辱，被欺负，被嘲笑，霸凌，如果你知道那是什么的话。
Tim started realizing that there was something different about him. And when Tim was around 12 years old, we were on our way to the grocery store and I was driving and Tim was sitting in the front seat next to me. And we hadn't been talking at all. I mean, the radio's going, you know. We're not talking to each other. And all of a sudden--
蒂姆开始意识到自己有些与众不同。当蒂姆12岁左右的时候，我们在去杂货店的路上，我开车，蒂姆坐在我旁边的副驾驶座上。我们一直没怎么说话。我的意思是，收音机开着，你知道。我们没有在交谈。突然——
I asked my mom, do I have a medical problem that you don't want to tell me about because you think I'm not mature enough to handle it?
我问妈妈，我是不是有什么医学问题，因为你觉得我不够成熟而不想告诉我？
We pulled over at the park and I stopped the car and I looked at him and I said, why do you want to know this? And he said, well, you know, you know, I just know that I'm different.
我们在公园旁停了车，我停下车看着他说，为什么你想知道这个？他说，嗯，你知道，你知道，我只是知道自己与众不同。
But she couldn't bring herself to tell him the truth. She didn't know if Tim was ready and she didn't feel ready. She said nothing.
但她无法说服自己告诉他真相。她不知道蒂姆是否准备好了，她自己也没有准备好。她什么也没说。
I was really, really-- probably lost some sleep over it. Because I kept going back and forth with, have I done the right thing keeping this from him? But at that time I wasn't sure.
我真的，真的——可能为此少睡了一些觉。因为我一直在反复纠结，我对他隐瞒这件事到底是对的吗？但在当时我无法确定。
No matter how hard I tried to, you know, make his world so great still kids picked on him. And so as years progressed-- one day he came home-- and he was about 14-- and he said, Mom, I feel like I'm the only person in the whole world that has the same problems as me. And it just broke my heart. My husband came home from work that night and I said, you know, we're going to have to probably pretty soon tell him.
无论我多么努力地想，你知道，让他的世界变得更美好，孩子们还是会欺负他。所以随着岁月的流逝——有一天他回到家——他大约14岁——他说，妈妈，我觉得我好像是世界上唯一一个有着和我一样问题的人。这让我心碎。那天晚上我丈夫下班回家，我说，你知道，我们可能很快就不得不告诉他了。
But they didn't. For another six whole months. It seemed so difficult. Here Kristy had to tell Tim that she'd kept the fundamental truth about his identity from him for most of his life. What's more, it seemed that her efforts to protect him might have actually made things worse.
但他们没有。又过了整整六个月。这看起来太难了。克里斯蒂不得不告诉蒂姆，她在他生命中的大部分时间里都对他隐瞒了关于他身份的基本事实。更重要的是，看起来她保护他的努力可能实际上让事情变得更糟了。
I think that we just worried how he was going to react. We didn't know how he was going-- we didn't know what to expect, at all, whatsoever. We didn't know if he would be happy or mad or sad or what. We just didn't know what to expect at all. And so, I think, that was our main worry.
我想我们只是担心他会作何反应。我们根本不知道他会——我们完全不知道会发生什么。我们不知道他会高兴、愤怒、悲伤还是怎样。我们完全不知道会发生什么。所以，我想，那是我们最担心的。
So we sat down on the couch. My husband tried to leave. And so Tim comes in from his bedroom and sits down and I said, we've got something to tell you. And he said, what? I said, remember how a while back you asked me if you had a medical problem that I didn't want you to know about? And he said, yes. And I said, do you remember when you said you felt like you're the only person in the whole world that had the problems that you had? And he said, yes.
所以我们坐在沙发上。我丈夫试图离开。蒂姆从卧室进来坐下，我说，我们有事要告诉你。他说，什么？我说，还记得前段时间你问我是否有什么医学问题，而我不想让你知道吗？他说，是的。我说，你还记得当你觉得你是世界上唯一一个有着和我一样问题的人时吗？他说，是的。
She told me I had Mosaic Down Syndrome. I don't know her exact words, but that's what she said.
她告诉我我有马赛克型唐氏综合征。我不记得她的确切措辞，但这就是她说的。
What came into your mind when she told you that?
当她告诉你那个的时候，你脑子里想到了什么？
Storm, Cyclops, Rogue, X-Men.
风暴女、独眼龙、罗刹女，X战警。
Why did X-Men come into your mind?
为什么你会想到X战警？
Because the X-Men are mutants, genetic. They gain those genetic problems, and that's what I felt like. I felt like an X-Men. And I thought that was kind of cool.
因为X战警是变种人，基因突变。他们获得了那些基因问题，那就是我的感觉。我觉得自己就像一个X战警。我觉得那还挺酷的。
And just like that, the truth was out. Ironically, what happened next was exactly the opposite of what Kristy had feared. Tim didn't seem angry. He didn't stop trying in school. The diagnosis actually made him more conscious of his strange behaviors, like the rocking on his heels, so he could work harder at controlling them.
就这样，真相大白了。讽刺的是，接下来的事情恰恰与克里斯蒂担心的相反。蒂姆似乎并没有生气。他没有放弃学习。这个诊断实际上让他更加意识到自己奇怪的行为，比如脚后跟的晃动，这样他就能更努力地控制它们。
Mostly he was relieved. He'd spent so many years feeling like there was something wrong with him that finding out there was wasn't so bad.
大多数时候他感到如释重负。他花了很多年觉得自己的某个地方不对劲，以至于发现原因其实也没那么糟糕。
In his junior year, Tim came out to his classmates during a presentation on genetics. After that, the kids started cutting him some slack. He wasn't the weird kid anymore. He was the kid with that Mosaic Down thing and you couldn't blame him for that.
在高二的时候，蒂姆在一次遗传学演讲中向同学公开了自己的病情。在那之后，孩子们开始宽容他了。他不再是那个奇怪的孩子了。他是那个患有“马赛克唐氏”的孩子，你不能因此责怪他。
So that was a real big turning point. He got a bunch of friends, real friends. And it was our first time to have real friends. And then these three big teenage boys came back to our house to spend the night. Never had such a thing. I mean, never.
所以那是一个真正的重大转折点。他交了一群朋友，真正的朋友。这是我们第一次拥有真正的朋友。后来这三个十几岁的大男孩回到我们家过夜。从来没发生过这种事。我是说，从来没有。
And so they're going to spend the night. And so we've got all these boys and I'm going, we've got to make popcorn. We've got to watch movies. After I got them settled, I came in the bedroom and I bawled my head off. Because it was just so wonderful. I mean, it was-- in fact, it was like 10:30 at night and I'm calling my mother, I have teenage boys in the house.
于是他们要过夜。我们这儿有这么多男孩子，我说，我们得爆些爆米花。我们得看电影。在他们安顿好之后，我回到卧室哭了个痛快。因为这太美妙了。我是说，这——事实上，当时是晚上10点半，我还在给我母亲打电话，我家里有十几岁的男孩。
You would think given how things turned out Kristy might have had some regrets about waiting so long to tell Tim the truth. I kept waiting for her to crack or something during our interview, to admit she'd made a mistake, but she didn't, and frankly, I was relieved.
你会认为鉴于事情的发展结果，克里斯蒂可能会对等待这么久才告诉蒂姆真相感到后悔。在采访中我一直在等她崩溃什么的，承认她犯了一个错误，但她没有，老实说，我感到如释重负。
I don't want to cast judgment on Kristy. Tim's a great kid. Whether that's because of what Kristy did or in spite of it, I don't think anyone can say. And anyway, Kristy and Tim have moved on to other issues, like teaching Tim how to balance a checkbook, how to drive, how to get ready to live on his own. And from Tim's point of view, Kristy's got her own learning to do.
我不想对克里斯蒂评头论足。蒂姆是个很棒的孩子。这是因为克里斯蒂所做的一切还是尽管如此，我不认为有人能说得准。无论如何，克里斯蒂和蒂姆已经转向了其他问题，比如教蒂姆如何平衡支票簿，如何开车，如何准备独立生活。从蒂姆的角度来看，克里斯蒂还有她自己需要学习的东西。
My mom is being a control freak right now. I'm going to be 20 this May. It's time I started to be a bit more independent.
我妈妈现在是个控制狂。我今年5月就满20岁了。我该开始更加独立了。
How will you have to change to be more independent?
为了更加独立，你需要做出什么改变？
When I leave this house, I plan to never wash dishes again.
当我离开这个家时，我打算再也不洗碗了。
Who's going to wash them?
谁来洗？
My wife. [LAUGHS] I'm kidding. I'll have the kids do it. [LAUGHS]
我老婆。[笑] 我开玩笑的。我会让孩子们去洗。[笑]
It's funny or maybe just typical. Tim's critical of his mom, but when I ask him how he thinks I should raise Anton, his advice to me is to do just what she did. Let people get to know Anton first before you tell them anything, Tim says to me. Tell Anton when he's a teenager, when he's old enough to handle it.
这很有趣，或者也许只是很典型。蒂姆批评他妈妈，但当我问他认为我应该如何抚养安东时，他给我的建议是做她做过的事。蒂姆对我说，先让人们了解安东，然后再告诉他们任何事情。等他十几岁，足够成熟去处理的时候再告诉他。
I know I probably won't do this. After all, Kristy's secrecy didn't protect Tim from pain, which is what I want for my son. So I'm back to square one with no trick to give Anton the perfect future, any more than I could give him those perfect chromosomes. And like any other parent, I'm waiting to see who my son becomes.
我知道我可能不会这样做。毕竟，克里斯蒂的隐瞒并没有保护蒂姆免受伤害，而这正是我想要的。所以我又回到了原点，没有秘诀能给安东一个完美的未来，就像我不能给他那些完美的染色体一样。像任何其他父母一样，我正等待着看我的儿子会成为什么样的人。
Karen Sosnoski. She's working on a book called, Love in the Time of Brain Tumors .
凯伦·索斯诺斯基。她正在写一本名为《脑瘤时期的爱》（Love in the Time of Brain Tumors）的书。
[MUSIC - "I  KNOW WHO I AM" BY BUNNY RUGS]
[音乐 - “I KNOW WHO I AM” BY BUNNY RUGS]
Act Two, "Financial Mousetrap." As you've probably heard by now, over the last few years the mortgage industry and the banking industry have been places that were rife with invention. People coming up with all kinds of better mousetraps, subprime mortgages and credit default swaps, and novel kinds of mortgage backed securities, all of which has sent the world's economy into a tailspin these last few weeks.
第二幕，“金融捕鼠器”。正如你现在可能已经听到的那样，在过去几年里，抵押贷款行业和银行业一直是充满发明的地方。人们想出各种更好的捕鼠器，次级抵押贷款和信用违约互换，以及新型的抵押贷款支持证券，所有这些在过去几周里都让全球经济陷入了混乱。
As part of our ongoing coverage of that mess, we now turn to the politics of all this. Last week on our radio show, we debunked an idea you hear a lot from Democrats these days. That this financial mess can be blamed entirely on Republicans deregulating financial markets. Today we take a look at the other side of the aisle.
作为我们对那场混乱持续报道的一部分，我们现在转向这一切背后的政治。上周在我们的广播节目中，我们反驳了最近在民主党人中经常听到的一个观点。即这场金融混乱可以完全归咎于共和党人放松了金融市场的管制。今天我们来看看天平的另一端。
This past week it seems to have actually hardened into a point of Republican dogma that the whole financial mess can be blamed on the Democrats. On Wednesday of this past week, I attended a McCain Palin rally in Lehigh, Pennsylvania. And I was amazed that nearly every person I talked to in this Republican crowd was quite certain who the culprits were behind our whole financial mess.
过去这一周，共和党人似乎形成了一种教条，即整个金融混乱可以完全归咎于民主党人。在本周三，我参加了宾夕法尼亚州利哈伊市的一次麦凯恩-佩林集会。令我惊讶的是，我交谈过的共和党人群体中的几乎每个人都非常确定谁才是我们整个金融混乱背后的罪魁祸首。
The liberal Democrats in the House encouraged and supported the notion that banks should be providing loans to people who couldn't afford them in inner city, wherever--
众议院的自由派民主党人鼓励并支持这样一种观点，即银行应该向那些在内城或其他任何地方负担不起的人提供贷款——
They saw McCain and Bush coming through with the regulations and they refused to do anything about it. Barney Frank said, no, it's OK. No problem. This is running great. And here we are today.
他们看到麦凯恩和布什提出监管措施，但他们拒绝采取任何行动。巴尼·弗兰克说，不，没关系。没问题。这运行得很好。而今天我们处于这个境地。
In this Republican version of the bailout story, there was a pivotal moment in 2005 when Republicans could have prevented a lot of the mess that we're in now, where they tried to regulate, where they tried to fix it, but the Democrats stopped them.
在这个共和党版的救市故事中，2005年是一个关键时刻，当时共和党人本可以阻止我们现在所处的许多混乱，他们试图监管，他们试图修复它，但民主党人阻止了他们。
And the key to the whole crisis, they say, was the mortgage companies Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae. They say Fannie and Freddie are at the center of the whole thing. Here's John McCain at the second presidential debate on Tuesday.
他们说，整个危机的关键在于抵押贷款公司房利美（Freddie Mac）和房地美（Fannie Mae）。他们说房利美和房地美是整个事情的核心。这是周二约翰·麦凯恩在第二次总统辩论中的发言。
Really the match that lit this fire was Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac. I'll bet you you may never even have heard of them before this crisis. But, you know, they're the ones that with the encouragement of Senator Obama and his cronies and his friends in Washington that went out and made all these risky loans, gave them to people that could never afford to pay back--
真正点燃这把火的确实是房利美和房地美。我敢打赌在这次危机之前你可能甚至没听说过它们。但是，你知道，正是它们在奥巴马参议员及其在华盛顿的亲信和朋友的鼓励下，走出去制造了所有这些风险贷款，把钱给那些永远负担不起还款的人——
So let's just start with the question, did the subprime crisis start with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac?
所以让我们从这个问题开始，次贷危机始于房利美和房地美吗？
Absolutely not. The subprime crisis did not start with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
绝对没有。次贷危机并非始于房利美和房地美。
This is Charles Duhigg who covers Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and other parts of the subprime crisis for the New York Times. He says that it was not Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac but Wall Street, international investors, brokers, and banks who created and popularized subprime mortgages. Fannie and Freddie didn't get involved in a serious way until relatively late.
这是查尔斯·杜伊格（Charles Duhigg），他为《纽约时报》报道房利美和房地美以及次贷危机的其他部分。他说，并不是房利美和房地美，而是华尔街、国际投资者、经纪人和银行创造并推广了次级抵押贷款。房利美和房地美直到相对较晚才严重介入。
This huge subprime economy had built. Wall Street came in and they said, we're going to basically buy any loan that anyone can make. And Fannie and Freddie at that point started losing a lot of their market share. So they started competing against Wall Street for worse and worse and riskier and riskier loans. And that, in turn, further fueled the growth of this thing.
这种巨大的次贷经济已经建立起来了。华尔街进来，他们说，我们要基本上买入任何人能做的任何贷款。而房利美和房地美在那时开始失去大量的市场份额。所以他们开始与华尔街竞争，购买越来越糟糕、风险越来越大的贷款。而这反过来又进一步助长了这东西的增长。
So what started out as a kind of small brush fire that was worrisome was fanned, over time, into a huge, huge blaze. And Fannie and Freddie were an important part of fanning that, but they didn't create the subprime economy. They weren't the single greatest input to the subprime economy. They were part of the problem.
所以起初是一场令人担忧的小火，随着时间的推移被煽动成了一场巨大、巨大的火灾。房利美和房地美在煽动这场火灾中起到了重要作用，但它们并没有创造次贷经济。它们不是次贷经济中单一最大的投入。它们是问题的一部分。
Nonetheless, Republicans say that if they'd been allowed to regulate Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac back in 2005, as they'd wanted, it would have prevented much of the current mess.
尽管如此，共和党人还是说，如果他们在2005年被允许监管房利美和房地美，正如他们所愿的那样，它本可以防止目前的许多混乱。
I was the one-- I was the one who called at the time for tighter restrictions on Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac that could have helped prevent this crisis, that could have helped prevent from happening in the first place and Senator Obama was silent on the regulation of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac. And his Democratic allies in Congress opposed every effort to rein them in.
我就是那个人——我就是当时呼吁对房利美和房地美实施更严格限制的人，这本可以帮助防止这场危机，本可以防止它最初发生，而奥巴马参议员对房利美和房地美的监管保持沉默。他在国会的民主党盟友反对每一次试图约束它们的努力。
So, Charles, what are they talking about? What did Republicans try to do a couple of years ago?
所以，查尔斯，他们在说什么？共和党人几年前试图做什么？
So in 2005, a couple of Republicans introduced legislation that would have placed greater restrictions on Fannie and Freddie. It would have empowered the regulator to basically have a tighter hold on them.
所以2005年，几名共和党人提出了立法，对房利美和房地美实施更大的限制。它将赋予监管机构更大的权力来控制它们。
Now what's important to keep in mind is John McCain didn't actually sponsor that legislation initially. He came to it kind of, you know, months and months after it had been introduced and after a big report had come out, saying that Fannie and Freddie are terrible companies. Everyone was kind of jumping on and John McCain jumped on to co-sponsor the legislation.
现在需要记住的重要一点是，约翰·麦凯恩最初并没有真正发起那项立法。他在该法案提出几个月后，在一份称房利美和房地美是糟糕公司的重要报告出炉后，才加入进来。每个人都跳上船，约翰·麦凯恩也跳上船去共同发起该立法。
People we've interviewed in the Senate have said that John McCain was never a big bugaboo on Fannie or Freddie, but he did co-sponsor the legislation. He deserves some credit for that.
我们在参议院采访过的人说，约翰·麦凯恩从来不是房利美或房地美问题的猛烈抨击者，但他确实共同发起了该立法。他在这方面值得称赞。
The 2005 legislation would have essentially done two things. First of all, it would have cut the number of loans that Fannie and Freddie can hold for themselves, so it would have avoided part of the problem that Freddie is having right now. And, theoretically, it might have caused Fannie and Freddie to stop buying so many risky loans, but that's not a guarantee.
2005年的立法本质上会做两件事。首先，它会削减房利美和房地美可以为自己持有的贷款数量，因此它会避免房地美现在正在遇到的一部分问题。理论上，它可能导致房利美和房地美停止购买如此多有风险的贷款，但这并不是保证。
In fact, it would have been completely up to the regulator. And the regulator who's holding the position right now is a man named James Lockhart. In the past year-- and he was a Bush appointee. In the past year, he actually helped Fannie and Freddie buy more and more riskier loans. Because Congress, over the past year, started asking Fannie and Freddie to buy risky loans because they thought that would help the economy.
事实上，这完全取决于监管机构。而目前担任该职位的人是一位名叫詹姆斯·洛克哈特（James Lockhart）的男子。在过去的一年里——他是由布什任命的。在过去的一年里，他实际上帮助房利美和房地美购买了更多、风险更大的贷款。因为国会在过去一年里开始要求房利美和房地美购买风险贷款，因为他们认为这会帮助经济。
Right now it's a part of a Republican orthodoxy, it seems, that if we had fixed Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in 2005, we wouldn't be in the crisis we're in today. Is that true?
现在看来，如果我们在2005年修复了房利美和房地美，我们就不会处于今天的危机中，这似乎已经成为一种共和党正统观念。这是真的吗？
That's absolutely not true. So if we had fixed Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in 2005, the crisis might be different and it might be slightly less, but the crisis would absolutely still be here.
这绝对不是真的。所以如果我们真的在2005年修复了房利美和房地美，危机可能会有所不同，程度可能会稍微轻一点，但危机绝对依然会在这里。
Another thing that's come up as a political talking point is the question of who associated with who. And Senator McCain said in Pennsylvania this week that executives of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac have advised Senator Obama.
另一个出现的政治谈资是谁与谁有联系的问题。麦凯恩参议员本周在宾夕法尼亚州表示，房利美和房地美的高管曾为奥巴马参议员提供咨询。
The executives of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac have advised him and he's taken their money for his campaign. In fact, he's received more money from Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac than any other senator in history, with the exception of the chairman of the committee overseeing them.
房利美和房地美的高管曾为他提供咨询，他也接受了他们的竞选捐款。事实上，他收到的来自房利美和房地美的资金比历史上任何其他参议员都多，监督它们的委员会主席除外。
The McCain Campaign also has an ad linking Barack Obama to an executive at Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
麦凯恩竞选团队还有一个广告将贝拉克·奥巴马与房利美和房地美的一位高管联系起来。
Obama has no background in economics. Who advises him? The Post says it's Franklin Raines for advice on mortgage and housing policy. Shocking. Under Raines, Fannie Mae committed extensive financial fraud. Raines made millions. Fannie Mae collapsed. Taxpayers? Stuck with the bill. Barack Obama. Bad advice. Bad instincts. Not ready to lead.
奥巴马没有经济背景。谁在为他出谋划策？《华盛顿邮报》说是富兰克林·雷恩斯（Franklin Raines），关于抵押贷款和住房政策的建议。令人震惊。在雷恩斯领导下，房利美进行了广泛的财务欺诈。雷恩斯赚了数百万。房利美崩溃了。纳税人？承担了账单。贝拉克·奥巴马。糟糕的建议。糟糕的直觉。没有准备好领导国家。
Franklin Raines.
富兰克林·雷恩斯。
Right. Which is based on-- apparently Barack Obama and Franklin Raines once bumped into each other at some type of get-together. What Barack Obama has said is that they had one conversation, very briefly, once. So it's a little disingenuous to say that Franklin Raines was an adviser to Barack Obama.
没错。显然是因为——贝拉克·奥巴马和富兰克林·雷恩斯曾经在某种聚会上碰到过。贝拉克·奥巴马所说的是，他们曾经非常简短地谈过一次话。所以说富兰克林·雷恩斯是贝拉克·奥巴马的顾问是有点虚伪的。
Now that being said, if you're following the money trail, if you want to say who's taken less or more money from Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac, Barack Obama-- it is absolutely true-- is the second highest recipient of lobbying dollars from Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
话虽如此，如果你追踪资金流向，如果你想说谁从房利美和房地美那里拿的钱更少或更多，贝拉克·奥巴马——这绝对是真的——是房利美和房地美游说资金的第二大受益者。
Now the reason why what John McCain is saying is a little disingenuous is because his campaign manager-- John McCain's campaign manager-- a guy named Rick Davis, was a lobbyist for Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac, and took over $2 million from them in lobbying fees to run this group that they had put together to try and fight back against more regulation. And, in fact, although Rick Davis left his firm when he joined the McCain campaign, his firm, that he still owns a part in, was receiving payments from Freddie Mac until earlier this year.
约翰·麦凯恩所说的话有点虚伪的原因是，他的竞选经理——约翰·麦凯恩的竞选经理——一个名叫里克·戴维斯（Rick Davis）的人，曾是房利美和房地美的说客，并从他们那里拿到了超过200万美元的游说费用，用于管理他们组建的一个旨在对抗更多监管的组织。事实上，虽然里克·戴维斯在加入麦凯恩竞选团队时离开了他的公司，但他仍然拥有部分所有权的公司，直到今年早些时候还在接收房地美的付款。
Until earlier this year or just until a month or two ago?
直到今年早些时候，还是直到一个月或两个月前？
Right. Yeah. Yeah. I think it ended in August. I'm not certain of exactly the date. And, in fact, I worked on the story breaking that. And what they said, the reason why Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac were paying Rick Davis-- John McCain's campaign manager-- is because they wanted access to John McCain. They thought that maybe he'd become President some day and so it would be good to be friends with the guy who's one of his closest aides.
没错。对。对。我认为是在八月结束的。我不确定确切的日期。事实上，我报道了这个独家新闻。他们所说的是，房利美和房地美支付给里克·戴维斯——约翰·麦凯恩的竞选经理——的原因是，他们想要接触约翰·麦凯恩。他们认为也许他有一天会成为总统，所以和他的亲信之一搞好关系会很有好处。
In general, Charles Duhigg says, it's true that Republicans have tried to rein in Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae for years. And it's true that, in general, Democrats have urged Fannie and Freddie to take on more loans and riskier loans and push for loose spending and low interest rates that led to the housing boom. And it's also true that Republicans fought regulation of the financial markets. But he says, none of that gets to the overall truth of what happened.
总体而言，查尔斯·杜伊格说，共和党人多年来确实试图约束房地美和房利美，这是事实。民主党人总体上敦促房利美和房地美承担更多贷款和风险贷款，并推动宽松的支出和低利率，从而导致了房地产繁荣，这也是事实。共和党人反对对金融市场进行监管，这也是事实。但他表示，这些都不能说明发生了什么的整体真相。
To say that either party had great foresight is completely untrue.
说任何一方有先见之明都是完全错误的。
So the blame for this is bipartisan.
所以这方面的责任是两党共同承担的。
The blame for this is absolutely bipartisan. Both parties deserve a great deal of blame for what happened with the subprime mess and to try and pin the blame on one party or the other really muddies the issue. A crisis like what's going on right now can't develop without everyone fueling it.
这方面的责任绝对是两党共同承担的。两党对次贷混乱中发生的事情都负有很大责任，试图把责任归咎于其中一方真的会混淆问题。像现在发生的危机不可能在每个人不推波助澜的情况下产生。
I mean, we're looking at the biggest crisis in a century. That only happens when basically everyone drops the ball. So there's enough blame to give to both parties here. When it comes down to specific individuals, some individuals deserve a lot more blame than others. And the Times is sepending a couple weeks basically trying to point our fingers at who deserves that blame.
我的意思是，我们面对的是一个世纪以来最大的危机。只有在基本上每个人都掉链子时才会发生这种情况。所以这里有足够的责任分给两党。当谈到特定个人时，有些人理应承担比其他人更多的责任。《纽约时报》花了几周时间基本上试图指明到底谁该承担这些责任。
And when you are looking at people who are especially good or especially bad, were Barack Obama and John McCain, either of them, especially great or especially terrible?
当你观察那些特别好或特别坏的人时，贝拉克·奥巴马和约翰·麦凯恩，他们中任何一个特别伟大或特别糟糕吗？
No. Barack Obama cares about a whole bunch of other things than Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and subprime. John McCain cares about a whole bunch of things besides Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and subprime. They spent most of their careers talking about things besides Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and subprime. This just wasn't a big issue for them.
没有。贝拉克·奥巴马关心房利美、房地美和次贷之外的一大堆事情。约翰·麦凯恩关心房利美、房地美和次贷之外的一大堆事情。他们职业生涯的大部分时间都在谈论房利美、房地美和次贷之外的事情。这对他们来说并不是一个大问题。
Charles Duhigg of the New York Times. On Friday, the McCain Campaign released a brand new ad that they say will run nationally linking Democrats to the financial crisis. It's along the lines that we've talked about. The ad says, "Congressional liberals fought for risky subprime loans. Congressional liberals fought against more regulation. Then the housing market collapsed, costing you billions."
《纽约时报》的查尔斯·杜伊格。周五，麦凯恩竞选团队发布了一个全新的广告，他们称将在全国范围内播放，将民主党人与金融危机联系起来。它沿着我们谈论的方向。广告说：“国会自由派争夺风险次贷。国会自由派反对更多监管。然后房地产市场崩溃，让你损失了数十亿。”
Regulators. We regulate any stealing of his property. We're damn good, too. But you can't be any geek off the street. You've got to be handy with the steel, if you know what I mean, to earn your keep. Regulators, mount up.
监管者。我们监管任何对他的财产的窃取行为。我们也相当擅长。但你不能是街头随便哪个书呆子。你得熟练使用钢刀，如果你们明白我的意思，才能赚到自己的那份钱。监管者，出发。
[MUSIC - "REGULATORS" BY WARREN G]
[音乐 - “REGULATORS” BY WARREN G]
Coming up, the underground economy comes up with its own plan to lose lots and lots of money and in their case it means cash money. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，地下经济提出了他们自己的亏钱计划，在他们的情况下，这意味着现金。稍后继续收听，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Make a Better Mousetrap. We have stories of people trying to make inventions in the face of a world that does not care, does not necessarily need or want what they're making. We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“制造更好的捕鼠器”。我们有关于人们试图在面对一个并不关心、也不一定需要或想要他们制造东西的世界时进行发明的案例故事。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, "Everything Must Go." In the early 1990s, Sudhir Alladi Venkatesh was researching the underground economies in the city of Chicago. He wanted to find out how people made money in the cash economy, off the books. And he spent a lot of time in the poorer areas of the city where people were inventing ways to make their livings.
第三幕，“清仓大甩卖”。20世纪90年代初，苏迪尔·阿拉迪·文卡泰什（Sudhir Alladi Venkatesh）正在研究芝加哥市的地下经济。他想弄清楚人们如何在现金经济中，在账外赚钱。他在芝加哥贫困地区花了很多时间，那里的人们正在发明谋生手段。
He hung out with women selling food from their homes, car mechanics who ran their business from an alleyway, store owners who hosted late night gambling and dice games. None of them, of course, was reporting their income to the government. Then there was Nellie, who had a problem that not many people faced. Here's Sudhir.
他和在家中卖饭的妇女、在巷子里经营生意的汽车修理工、举办深夜赌博和掷骰子游戏的店主打成一片。当然，他们中没有人向政府申报收入。然后是内利（Nellie），他遇到了一个没几个人面临的问题。这是苏迪尔的叙述。
Nellie Thomas was a hustler who worked in and around his South Side neighborhood and over the course of his life, he was a pimp, drug dealer, car thief, extorter, jackroller, prostitute and burglar. I met Nellie because I wanted to know how people bought guns in Chicago.
内利·托马斯是一个在南区社区及其周边混迹的骗子，在他一生中，他做过皮条客、毒贩、偷车贼、敲诈犯、劫匪、妓女和窃贼。我认识内利是因为我想知道人们如何在芝加哥买枪。
By the time I met him, Nellie had made a name for himself not because he sold guns, but because he sold ammunition. It's illegal to buy handguns in the city of Chicago. For guns and ammo, people usually have to trek out to the suburbs, which isn't so easy. Most gun stores are in white suburbs and the Black people in Nellie's community don't like to go there, so they buy guns in their own neighborhood for the most part.
当我认识他时，内利已经出名了，不是因为他卖枪，而是因为他卖弹药。在芝加哥市购买手枪是非法的。对于枪支和弹药，人们通常不得不长途跋涉去郊区，这并不容易。大多数枪店都在白人郊区，内利社区的黑人不喜欢去那里，所以他们大部分时间是在自己的社区买枪。
Now in the South Side where Nellie lived, if you have money and a little patience, you can probably find a gun within a few days. But it's a lot harder to find ammo. Nellie understood this and he capitalized on the demand by becoming an ammunitions trader.
现在在内利居住的南区，如果你有钱和一点耐心，你很可能在几天内找到枪。但找弹药要难得多。内利明白这一点，他通过成为弹药贸易商来利用这种需求。
Nellie would drive to the suburbs or he'd hire people to go there and buy boxes of ammo for a few dollars each. Back in his own neighborhood, it might cost you $100 for a box. He sold bullets to gang members, robbers, drug dealers, prostitutes and just regular people who liked to have a weapon around.
内利会开车去郊区，或者雇人去那里买几箱弹药，每箱只要几美元。回到自己的社区，一箱可能要你100美元。他把子弹卖给帮派成员、抢劫犯、毒贩、妓女以及喜欢身边有武器的普通人。
And when the gang wars heated up in the mid- to late-90s, people bought several boxes at a time and Nellie was flush with cash. "Good money. No hassle," he'd like to say. "Cops don't care much about me."
当90年代中期到后期的帮派战争加剧时，人们一次买好几箱，内利财源滚滚。“钱好赚。没麻烦，”他喜欢这样说。“警察不太关心我。”
When I started hanging out with Nellie, he was becoming bothered by his success. He was making so much money that he didn't know what to do with it. His needs were pretty minimal. He had a beat up old truck that he fixed himself. And his parents had long ago paid off the mortgage on the bungalow where he was born and where he still lived. The house was a kind of modest, two-story and basement and backyard design that you could see all over Chicago.
当我开始和内利混在一起时，他正被自己的成功所困扰。他赚了太多钱，以至于不知道该怎么办。他的需求非常少。他有一辆自己修理的破旧货车。他的父母很久以前就还清了他出生并在那里生活的平房的抵押贷款。这所房子是一种在芝加哥随处可见的适中、两层楼加地下室和后院的设计。
Nellie was hardly a big consumer. He liked to listen to a pocket-sized radio. And although he had a fancy TV, he usually watched a little black-and-white in his bedroom. And he never traveled. For 20 years, he'd been eating at the same soul food restaurant every day. He wore the same three or four pairs of clothes. And almost every day you could see him walking or playing golf-- "Very badly," he said-- in the park next to his house.
内利几乎不是什么大消费者。他喜欢听袖珍收音机。虽然他有一台豪华电视，但他通常在卧室看一台小型黑白电视。他从不出门。20年来，他每天都在同一家灵魂乐餐厅吃饭。他穿着同样的几套衣服。几乎每天你都能看到他走路或在他家隔壁的公园打高尔夫——“非常烂，”他说。
Nellie also lived in a world of cash. Like most underground traders, he couldn't take large sums of money to the bank, and for small sums he simply didn't trust banks. So he put his cash in mattresses and in large black trash bags that he hid inside his house, or that he buried outside in the backyard.
内利也生活在一个现金世界里。像大多数地下商人一样，他不能把大笔钱存入银行，而对于小数额，他干脆不信任银行。所以他把现金放在床垫里，放在他藏在屋子里的黑色大垃圾袋里，或者埋在后院外面。
But Nellie was losing sleep because he was running out of places to keep his cash. He worried because there were other people living in his home, a girlfriend and her two children, a niece, his grandmother, an aunt, and a brother with his girlfriend and two kids. Nellie was scared he'd be robbed and so he began staying up all night with a big shotgun next to his window.
但内利整夜失眠，因为他没地方放现金了。他很担心，因为家里住着其他人，一个女朋友和她的两个孩子、一个侄女、他的祖母、一位姑妈，还有一个带着女朋友和两个孩子的兄弟。内利害怕被抢劫，所以他开始整夜坐在窗边，手里拿着一把大猎枪。
His anxiety grew so bad that he started taking medication and drinking more. He was restless and fidgety and he said he was yelling at his family for no good reason. Sometimes he'd call me early in the morning. We both knew many of the local gang leaders and he wanted me to tell him whether they were planning to raid his house.
他的焦虑变得如此严重，以至于他开始服药并喝更多的酒。他坐立不安，焦躁易怒，他说自己无缘无故地对家人大喊大叫。有时他会在清晨给我打电话。我们都知道许多当地的帮派头目，他想让我告诉他他们是否计划突袭他的房子。
He also asked me strange questions, like whether squirrels could smell paper money and whether they would dig in his backyard and eat his holdings. He admitted he was going to the hospital nearly every two weeks due to panic attacks.
他还问我一些奇怪的问题，比如松鼠能否闻到纸币的气味，它们会不会在他后院挖洞吃掉他的钱。他承认因为恐慌症，他几乎每两周就得去一次医院。
At first I wondered why Nellie didn't just give his money away to his family, or to a charity, but it wasn't so simple for him. He said he was ashamed of how he'd earned it. He didn't want to tell people that he sold ammo to gang members for a living. I suppose Nellie could have bought some property or found a way to launder his money but that really wasn't in his character. Nellie didn't think in terms of the future, at least not in that way. And because he was very depressed and his job was so dangerous, Nellie didn't think he'd live long enough to spend his money on anything worthwhile.
起初我纳闷为什么内利不直接把钱分给家人或捐给慈善机构，但对他来说没那么简单。他说他为自己如何挣到这些钱感到羞愧。他不想告诉人们他是靠卖弹药给帮派成员谋生的。我想内利本可以买些房产或者找个方法洗钱，但这真的不是他的性格。内利不以未来的眼光思考，至少不是那种眼光。而且因为他非常抑郁，工作又如此危险，内利不认为自己能活得足够长久，把钱花在任何有价值的事情上。
One morning I went to Nellie's house and found him in tears. No one was home and he was lying on his bed with his money all over the room. He kept saying he couldn't take it anymore and he wanted a way out.
一天早上我去了内利家，发现他泪流满面。家里没别人，他躺在床上，满屋子都是钱。他不停地说他再也受不了了，他想找个出路。
I noticed a few large bills but there were mostly piles and piles of one and five dollar bills crumpled up like waste paper. He was pleading with me to help him to do something with all of his money, which he estimated was about $15,000 or $20,000.
我注意到几张大额钞票，但大部分是一堆堆揉得像废纸一样的1美元和5美元纸币。他恳求我帮他处理掉他所有的钱，他估计大约有1.5万到2万美元。
He asked me, "What do your people do when they have all the stuff that they can't use?" I'm Indian, but I assumed he meant middle-class folks. "Well," I said, "when my family has a lot of stuff, we give it away or we have a garage sale." His eyes lit up. "That's it. I'm going to have a garage sale." I wasn't sure I understood what he meant. "Let me get this straight. You're going to sell your money?" He grinned, stood up, hugged me, and said, "Thank you, thank you, thank you for getting me out of this mess."
他问我，“当你的人有所有这些用不上的东西时，你们会怎么做？”我是印度人，但我假设他指的是中产阶级。“嗯，”我说，“当我们家有很多东西时，我们会把它送人，或者举办庭院甩卖。”他的眼睛亮了起来。“就是这个。我要办个庭院甩卖。”我不确定我是否理解他的意思。“等一下。你是说你要卖掉你的钱？”他咧嘴一笑，站起身，拥抱了我，说：“谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你帮我摆脱这个烂摊子。”
So I made myself a cup of coffee, sat on the couch, and watched as Nellie put some of the money inside a television. Then he dumped a handful of bills inside a vacuum cleaner. Then he shoved bags full of cash inside his couch cushions and in a mattress. He picked up a basketball, examined it, looked over to me, and agreed when I shook my head, no.
所以我给自己冲了一杯咖啡，坐在沙发上，看着内利把一些钱塞进电视机里。然后他把一把钞票倒进真空吸尘器里。然后他把装满现金的袋子塞进沙发垫和床垫里。他拿起一个篮球，端详了一下，看了一眼我，当我摇头时，他也表示同意。
And then with my help, he dragged everything out to the front lawn. He ran into the garage and came back with a hammer, nails, and cardboard. He made several for sale signs and tacked them on to the trees and on the windshield of his car.
然后在我帮助下，他把所有东西都拖到了前院。他跑进车库，带回一把锤子、钉子和纸板。他做了几个“出售”标牌，把它们钉在树上和他的车挡风玻璃上。
He was so happy. He was running around like a child building a tree house. For his final gesture, Nellie ran back inside the house, grabbed two chairs and a six pack of beer and brought them outside. He told me that I couldn't tell anyone what he just did.
他太高兴了。他跑来跑去，就像一个正在建树屋的孩子。作为最后的举动，内利跑回屋里，拿了两把椅子和一箱啤酒拿到外面。他告诉我，我不能告诉任何人他刚才做了什么。
I exchanged my coffee for a beer and sat on Nellie's well-manicured front lawn unsure of exactly what was supposed to transpire. We sat on the lawn for about 10 minutes. I was getting a little agitated. My cell phone rang. Nellie looked at me and said, "Remember. You can't say what's in them things. You can't mention the money."
我用咖啡换了啤酒，坐在内利修剪得很好的前草坪上，不确定到底会发生什么。我们在草坪上坐了大约10分钟。我开始有点焦躁。我的手机响了。内利看着我说：“记住。你不能说那些东西里面有什么。你不能提到钱。”
It was a friend of mine, Autry. He had three children and he had been looking for a job for about a year and now he was living off food stamps and was about three months late on his car and rent payments. Autry could definitely have used the money not to mention the nice TV set sitting in front of my feet.
是我朋友奥特里（Autry）打来的。他有三个孩子，失业快一年了，现在靠食品券生活，车贷和房租已经拖欠了大约三个月。奥特里绝对用得上这笔钱，更不用说我脚边放着的那台好电视了。
"I'm at a garage sale," I told Autry, checking with Nellie to see if that was OK. Nellie nodded approval. "You should come over," I said checking with Nellie again, who didn't nod. "Autry, listen. You should really come over and see if anything interests you." Autry asked me why the hell would I want him to come to a garage sale when I knew he didn't have any money. I kept telling him to come anyway. Nellie began shaking his head. I sank in my chair, lowered my voice and told Autry to call me if he found some cash and wanted to buy some appliances, and then I hung up.
“我在参加一个庭院甩卖，”我告诉奥特里，核实内利是否同意。内利点头表示同意。“你应该过来，”我说，再次向内利确认，但他没有点头。“奥特里，听着。你真的应该过来看看有没有你感兴趣的东西。”奥特里问我，当我明知道他没钱时，为什么要叫他来参加庭院甩卖。我一直告诉他一定要过来。内利开始摇头。我瘫在椅子上，压低声音告诉奥特里如果他发现了现金想买些家电再打给我，然后挂断了电话。
Nellie and I waited for what seemed like hours though my watch said only 20 minutes had passed. Every so often I asked him again whether he really wanted to do this. He would just stare out and tell me that he'd never been more sure about anything in his life. "I feel like the Lord gave me a sign," he said.
内利和我等了似乎有几个小时，尽管我的手表显示才过去了20分钟。我每隔一会儿就再问他一次他是否真的想这么做。他只会望着外面告诉我，他一生中从未如此肯定过任何事。“我觉得上帝给了我一个启示，”他说。
Just then a woman came by and looked at the couch. I leaned forward as if to pounce out of my chair and I could see that Nellie was doing the same. "Nice couch," she said. "Yeah," said Nellie. "You ain't never going to find another one like it."
就在这时，一个女人走过来，看着沙发。我向前探身，仿佛要从椅子上扑出去，我能看出内利也在做同样的事。“好沙发，”她说。“是的，”内利说。“你永远找不到像这样的另一张了。”
"That's right, ma'am," I chimed in. "This is certainly a one-of-a-kind couch. You can take my word for it." "$20," she said. "For a couch?" said Nellie. "Ma'am, I need to make a little more than that." "But, sir," she said, trying to be polite, "it ain't worth more than that."
“没错，夫人，”我附和道。“这绝对是独一无二的沙发。你可以相信我的话。”“20美元，”她说。“买个沙发？”内利说。“夫人，我需要多赚一点。”“但是，先生，”她试图礼貌地说道，“它不值那么多钱。”
"Ma'am," I said, "I think on that count you are mistaken. It is certainly worth more." "Hey, shut up," Nellie yelled at me. The woman watched as Nellie and I began bickering. "You two need help," she said, and walked away.
“夫人，”我说，“我认为这一点你弄错了。它绝对值更多。”“嘿，闭嘴，”内利对我喊道。那个女人看着内利和我开始争吵。“你们两个需要帮助，”她说，然后走开了。
As the morning turned to afternoon, more people came. The first successful sale was to a man pushing a shopping cart. He eyed the vacuum cleaner.
随着上午变成下午，更多的人来了。第一次成功的销售是卖给了一个推着购物车的男人。他打量着真空吸尘器。
"What do you want for it?" he asked. "Give me $15," said Nellie. "$15. Are you nuts?" I said. I couldn't believe Nellie would charge so little. Nellie shot me a glance and I put my head in my hands.
“你想要多少钱？”他问道。“给我15美元，”内利说。“15美元。你疯了吗？”我说。我无法相信内利会要价这么低。内利朝我投来一眼，我双手抱头。
"$15, my man, and it's all yours," Nellie said calmly. "All right. That'll work," the man said. He paid Nellie with some bills and a lot of loose change. Then he grinned and said within an hour he could sell the vacuum cleaner down at the thrift store for $30, double his take, just like that.
“15美元，哥们，它是你的了，”内利冷静地说。“好吧。成交，”那人说。他用一些钞票和许多零钱付给了内利。然后他咧嘴一笑说，一小时内他就能在旧货店以30美元的价格卖掉真空吸尘器，翻倍收入，就是这样。
"You might want to take it home first," I told the man as he started walking away. "Just clean it out. Put a fresh bag in. Try it out. Take it apart, maybe." "Home?" the man said, looking at me. "Boy, are you blind or something? I live out of this cart. I live under the EL tracks. Home? [BLEEP] I ain't got no home. [BLEEP] What am I going to do with a vacuum cleaner?"
“你可能想先把它带回家，”当他开始走开时，我告诉那个人。“清理干净。换个新袋子。试用一下。拆开来看看，也许。”“家？”那人看着我说。“小子，你瞎了吗？我住在车里。我住在高架铁路下面。家？[哔]我没有家。[哔]我拿真空吸尘器干什么？”
A Saturday morning church service must've ended because a line of black women wearing beautiful dresses and hats was coming our way. They looked at the items on the lawn and liked what they saw. One played with the television set, hitting it every so often while a few others sat on the couch.
周六早上的礼拜一定结束了，因为一排穿着漂亮裙子和帽子的黑人妇女正朝我们走来。她们看着草坪上的物品，喜欢她们所看到的。一个人玩着电视机，不时拍打它，而另外几个人则坐在沙发上。
"A little soft and, well, not so even," one said to me and Nellie. "These cushions are a little old, aren't they? How old are they?" "Oh, they're fairly new," I said. "Made fresh this morning actually." "Boy," Nellie yelled at me. This time he threw some beer on me.
“有点软，而且，好吧，不太平整，”一个人对我和内利说。“这些垫子有点旧了，不是吗？它们有多久了？”“哦，它们相当新，”我说。“事实上是今天早上刚做的。”“小子，”内利对我喊道。这次他向我泼了一些啤酒。
"Don't mind him, ma'am. He's not the God-fearing sort. You understand." The woman cast a disparaging look my way and said, "Mm hm, I understand and Jesus do, too. OK, I'll take this couch. Probably throw these cushions away. The other parts are fine but I can't have people sitting on these raggedy things all day." "I would rethink that strategy," I shouted. My voice crackled and beer spilled down my shirt. "I'd probably not throw them away just yet."
“别介意他，夫人。他不是敬畏上帝的那种人。你应该明白。”那个女人向我投来轻蔑的目光说：“嗯，我明白，耶稣也明白。好吧，我要这个沙发。可能会把这些垫子扔掉。其他部分很好，但我不能让人整天坐在这些破烂玩意儿上。”“我会重新考虑那个策略，”我大喊。我的声音嘶哑，啤酒顺着衬衫流了下来。“我可能不会现在就把它们扔掉。”
"What he means to say," Nellie interrupted, "is that you may want to take it home first. Don't do anything so quick. You know, take your time." "I'm not sure there's really anything to think about," a second woman said, feeling the cushions stuffed with America's legal tender. "Yunella, you could replace these for $5. Ain't no need wasting your time with these cushions. Smell like cat piss anyway. Just throw them out."
“他的意思是，”内利打断道，“你可能想先带回家。别做得这么快。你知道，慢慢来。”“我不确定真的有什么可考虑的，”第二个女人说道，感受着塞满美国法定货币的垫子。“尤内拉（Yunella），你花5美元就能换掉这些垫子。根本没必要在这上面浪费时间。闻起来像猫尿一样。直接扔掉就行。”
"Oh, lord, I'd really think twice about that," I said, bending over in frustration. I was starting to feel delirious. "Why don't you go inside for a while," Nellie said, pushing me over and making me fall on the ground. I got up and walked toward the house.
“哦，天哪，我真的会三思而后行，”我沮丧地弯下腰。我开始感到神志不清。“为什么你不进去待一会儿，”内利说，推了我一把，使我倒在地上。我爬起来走向屋子。
"What is wrong with that young man?" I could hear the woman ask Nellie. "Oh, nothing that a little religion couldn't fix," Nellie said. Then he told them, "Listen, the truth is, ma'am, that I'm trying to buy my family all new furniture before they get home and I really need to sell this stuff and get rid of it so that I can surprise my wife."
“那个年轻人怎么了？”我能听到那个女人问内利。“哦，没什么一点信仰解决不了的问题，”内利说。然后他告诉她们，“听着，真相是，夫人，我正试图在我家人回家之前给他们买一套全新的家具，我真的需要卖掉这些东西并处理掉，这样我就能给我的妻子一个惊喜。”
"Oh, isn't that sweet," one of the women said. "Well, I'll take the television." "Yes," another one chimed in, "and I could use an extra bed." "I'd keep that mattress," I shouted from inside the house. "Don't throw away the mattress, please." "That is the strangest young man I have ever seen," one of the women said. "Yes," said Nellie. He twirled his finger in little circles next to his head. "He has a little bit of trouble, you know."
“哦，这太甜了，”其中一个女人说。“嗯，我要这台电视。”“是的，”另一个人附和道，“我可以再要一张床。”“我会留着那张床垫的，”我从屋里大喊。“别扔掉床垫，求求你了。”“这是我见过最奇怪的年轻人，”其中一个女人说。“是的，”内利说。他在头旁边转着手指。“他有点麻烦，你知道的。”
The woman then turned to me and spoke very slowly. "You be careful now, young man. And beer probably isn't very good for your health." "Neither is throwing away that mattress, ma'am."
那个女人然后转向我，非常缓慢地说道。“你现在要小心点，年轻人。而且啤酒可能对你的健康不太好。”“扔掉那张床垫也不太好，夫人。”
Nellie asked the women for their address and he loaded the bed into the truck and drove off. I drank the rest of the beers and stared out into a warm blue sky. Nellie sold almost everything on the lawn that afternoon. The only thing that was left was a torn up pillow that couldn't attract anyone's interest. I tried for a while to find the people who had bought some of Nellie's furniture and appliances, but I didn't have any luck, so I'm not really sure if any of them found the cash.
内利询问了女人的地址，把床装上卡车，然后开车走了。我喝光了剩下的啤酒，望着温暖的蓝天。内利那天下午卖掉了草坪上几乎所有东西。唯一剩下的是一个没人感兴趣的破枕头。我试着找了一段时间那些买了内利家具和家电的人，但没能成功，所以我真的不知道她们中是否有任何人发现了现金。
Nellie didn't have anymore garage sales. He was still making money by selling ammo and he still kept the money in those big black garbage bags. He just stored them all in the attic where nobody ever went.
内利没再办过庭院甩卖。他仍然靠卖弹药赚钱，而且他仍然把钱放在那些大黑垃圾袋里。他只是把它们全存在没人去过的阁楼里。
And Nellie's depression didn't end. For most people, all that money would have been a sign of success, but for Nellie it was just a bunch of paper that he couldn't get rid of. His problem was that he liked his job. He liked the fact that he worked and that he earned a living. The part he didn't like was the actual profits. They made him feel ashamed and he had to hide them from almost everyone he knew and loved.
内利的抑郁症并没有结束。对大多数人来说，所有的钱都是成功的标志，但对内利来说，那只是一堆他无法摆脱的纸。他的问题是他喜欢他的工作。他喜欢他工作并赚取生活费的事实。他不喜欢的其实是那些利润。它们让他感到羞愧，他不得不对自己认识和爱的几乎所有人隐藏它们。
A few years later, Nellie's girlfriend left him, his kids married and moved out, and there was no one else living in his house. He started going to church to ease his depression. It wasn't really helping, he said. But he did start talking a lot about charity and how he wanted to do something good for people. And he did it in his own peculiar way.
几年后，内利的女朋友离开了他，孩子们结婚搬了出去，家里没别人了。他开始去教堂以减轻抑郁。他说那并没真正起到作用。但他确实开始多谈论慈善，以及他想为人们做些好事。而且他以自己独特的方式做到了。
Nellie would leave a bag of money on a street corner or late at night he would quietly put some cash in front of a homeless person sleeping outside in the park. He would tell me that it was the only pure thing you can do on this earth, help people without taking credit for it.
内利会把一袋钱留在街角，或者在深夜悄悄地把一些现金放在公园外睡觉的无家可归者面前。他会告诉我，这是你在地球上能做的唯一纯粹的事情，不求回报地帮助人们。
I know of only one person who actually found Nellie's money, my friend Darrell. Nellie had stuffed $800 into the bottom part of a toaster oven and he left it near a dumpster where Darrell picked it up. Darrell figured some drug dealer had hidden the money there so his wife wouldn't find it and she accidentally threw the toaster out.
我知道只有一个真正发现内利钱的人，我的朋友达雷尔（Darrell）。内利把800美元塞进了一个烤箱底部的部分，并把它留在了一个垃圾箱附近，达雷尔捡到了它。达雷尔认为某个毒贩把钱藏在那里是为了不让妻子发现，结果她不小心把烤箱扔了。
A day before his 45th birthday, Nellie was found dead inside his house. He'd had a massive stroke. No one was quite sure exactly how long he'd been lying there. I went to his funeral. Not many people were there and I felt sad for Nellie. I hoped that maybe the homeless man who had bought the vacuum cleaner would come pay his respects, but he didn't show up. In the middle of the room there was a casket but it was closed. Nellie's body was too decomposed for us to view.
在他45岁生日的前一天，人们发现内利死在屋里。他中风了。没人确定他到底躺在那里多久了。我参加了他的葬礼。没几个人在那里，我为内利感到难过。我希望也许那个买真空吸尘器的无家可归者会来表示敬意，但他没露面。房间中央有一个棺材，但它是关着的。内利的尸体分解得太严重，我们无法观看。
In the end, Nellie's family got all his money when they cleaned out his house. That's when I finally met them. They told me that they'd known all along the thing that Nellie was ashamed for them to find out, how he made his money. But they could never figure out a way to tell him that it didn't matter.
最终，内利的家人在清理他的房子时得到了他所有的钱。那时我终于见到了他们。他们告诉我，他们一直都知道内利因被发现而羞愧的那件事，也就是他是如何赚钱的。但他们始终没能找到方法告诉他，这根本不重要。
Sudhir Alladi Venkatesh. His most recent book is called, Gang Leader For a Day . It tells the story of the neighborhood in and around the Robert Taylor Homes in Chicago. He's a professor of sociology at Columbia University.
苏迪尔·阿拉迪·文卡泰什。他最近的一本书名为《一日帮派领袖》（Gang Leader For a Day）。它讲述了芝加哥罗伯特·泰勒住宅区及周边社区的故事。他是哥伦比亚大学的社会学教授。
[MUSIC - "EVERYTHING MUST GO" BY WEAKERTHANS]
[音乐 - “EVERYTHING MUST GO” BY WEAKERTHANS]
Act Four, "The Not-For-Profit Motive." In responding to the current financial crisis, our government has had to invent all kinds of better mousetraps to fix the mess. With that in mind, one quick follow up to something I have here. It was on last week's radio show.
第四幕，“非营利动机”。在应对当前的金融危机时，我们的政府不得不发明各种更好的捕鼠器来解决混乱。考虑到这一点，对我这里的一些事情做一个简短的跟进。那是上周的广播节目。
Last week NPR'S economics correspondent, Adam Davidson, reported on our program that one of these inventions, the Wall Street Bailout Bill included, buried deep inside, something called stock injection that had a number of advantages over the original bailout plan. The way it worked is that rather than buy a bank's toxic assets, stock injection would essentially buy stock in the bank. Infuse the bank with cash that way.
上周，NPR的经济记者亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）在我们的节目中报道称，这些发明之一，华尔街救市法案（Wall Street Bailout Bill），深埋在里面，包含了某种称为股票注入（stock injection）的东西，它比最初的救市计划有许多优势。它的运作方式是，与其购买银行的毒资产，股票注入本质上将购买银行的股票。通过这种方式向银行注入现金。
The banking industry and government officials mostly seemed to hate this idea a week ago, but if you've followed the news of this last week, treasury officials have now declared in the last couple days that they might actually try the stock injection plan. That would be in addition to their original plan of buying toxic assets. The advantage of the stock injection is that they can do it quicker.
银行业和政府官员一周前大多似乎讨厌这个主意，但如果你关注了过去一周的新闻，财政部官员在过去几天里已经宣布，他们实际上可能会尝试股票注入计划。这将是对他们最初购买毒资产计划的补充。股票注入的优势在于他们可以做得更快。
With this action and many others recently, the government is reinventing itself, doing certain things that it has never done before. Alex Blumberg had been trying to figure out exactly what that means.
通过这一行动和最近的许多其他行动，政府正在重塑自身，做一些它从未做过的事情。亚历克斯·布隆伯格一直试图弄清楚这到底意味着什么。
Here's how the US government usually behaves. It borrows money, in the form of selling treasury bonds, and then it spends that money on stuff for the country, Black Hawk helicopters, or cancer research, an occasional bridge to nowhere, stuff in the budget.
这是美国政府通常的行为方式。它通过出售国债来借钱，然后把这些钱花在国家的事情上，黑鹰直升机，或癌症研究，偶尔建一座通往虚无的桥梁，预算里的东西。
But with the passage of the bailout bill, it's going to be doing something entirely different with that money. It's going to be buying up mortgage related assets from banks. And that's not all. Just this week it announced it would start lending the money it raises directly to individual companies in something called the commercial paper market.
但随着救市法案的通过，它将用这些钱做一些完全不同的事情。它将从银行购买抵押贷款相关的资产。而且还不止这些。就在本周，它宣布将开始直接向个别公司借出它筹集的资金，在一种称为商业票据市场的东西中。
Brad Setser is an economist at the Council on Foreign Relations and he used to work in the Treasury Department. NPR's Adam Davidson and I sat down with him a couple of days ago, and he told us that by doing all these new things, the United States has started acting like something completely different than a government.
布拉德·塞策（Brad Setser）是外交关系委员会的经济学家，他曾在财政部工作。NPR的亚当·戴维森和我几天前与他坐下来交流，他告诉我们，通过做所有这些新事情，美国已经开始表现得像一个与政府完全不同的东西。
It's starting to act like a bank. It is borrowing money by selling these short term treasuries and lending to the banking system and lending to firms like GE and others that are big players in the commercial paper market.
它开始表现得像一家银行。它通过出售这些短期国库券借钱，并借贷给银行系统，并借贷给GE（通用电气）和其他像在商业票据市场中的大玩家这样的公司。
So instead of borrowing money and then building a bridge, it is borrowing money and then investing it, giving it to a company as a loan that will be paid back or something like that.
所以与其借钱然后建一座桥，它是在借钱然后投资，给一家公司一笔贷款，这些贷款会被还清之类的。
That's the big change that happened today. And then in addition to doing all that, there's the $700 billion that's going to be used to buy assets that are harder to value and harder to sell and in that, it is also acting like a bank or an investment bank. But it's not acting completely like a bank, because if it was acting completely like a bank, it'd be trying to drive the hardest possible bargain so it can make the most money.
这就是今天发生的巨大变化。除此之外，还有那7000亿美元将用于购买更难估值、更难出售的资产，在这一点上，它也表现得像一家银行或一家投资银行。但它并不完全像一家银行，因为如果它完全表现得像一家银行，它会试图达成尽可能艰难的协议，以便它能赚到最多的钱。
The US government doesn't want to do that because making the most possible money means, in effect, buying these assets at the lowest prices possible. And there's a problem with that.
美国政府不想这样做，因为赚最多的钱意味着，实际上，以尽可能低的价格购买这些资产。这有个问题。
The problem is that if you drive too hard of a bargain, if you're doing this is as a pure financial bet, sort of--
问题是，如果你达成过于艰难的协议，如果你这样做是为了某种纯粹的金融赌注——
Go for the kill.
去杀戮。
--go for the kill, get them at the lowest possible price, the banks are bust. So it's acting like a really badly run bank.
——去杀戮，以尽可能低的价格买到它们，银行就破产了。所以它表现得像一家经营极差的银行。
It's like, well, nobody else will pay you more than, you know, $0.20 on the dollar for those things but we'll give you $0.40.
就像，嗯，没有别人会为你支付超过，你知道，1美元折算20美分购买那些东西，但我们会给你40美分。
Yes. But it's doing so for a reason which is that if the banks had to sell at $0.20, they're bust.
是的。但它这样做是有原因的，那就是如果银行必须以20美分出售，它们就破产了。
Right. Right. Right. I'm not saying that it shouldn't be doing that. It's just sort of sucks that the US government is in this position that it's not normally in, which is to try to behave half like a business and half like a government.
对。对。对。我不是说它不应该这样做。只是美国政府处于这种它通常不处的境地，即试图表现得一半像企业一半像政府，这真有点糟。
This is what-- I mean, you all are shocked. I used to work on emerging economies. This is what happens when you have a really bad crisis. This is what happens when the banking system is on the edge of collapse.
这就是——我的意思是，你们都很震惊。我过去常在新兴经济体工作。这就是当你面临非常糟糕的危机时发生的事情。这就是当银行系统处于崩溃边缘时发生的事情。
So it's just that this has happened before, it just hasn't happened to the US before.
所以这只是发生过，只是之前没在美国发生过而已。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Where has it happened?
在哪里发生过？
Indonesia. Thailand. Argentina. Russia.
印度尼西亚。泰国。阿根廷。俄罗斯。
OK, let's review that list. Indonesia, leadership deposed. Argentina, leadership deposed. Thailand, leadership forced to resign. Russia, leadership returned to authoritarian roots.
好的，让我们回顾一下那个名单。印度尼西亚，领导层被罢免。阿根廷，领导层被罢免。泰国，领导层被迫辞职。俄罗斯，领导层回归威权根基。
It's generally not good for any political system if your banks come close to collapsing. It's not a good thing.
如果你的银行接近崩溃，对任何政治体制来说通常都不是好事。这不是件好事。
So I just don't know how to feel. Should we be very upset that they're doing this or should we be upset that the situation required them to do it but glad that they're doing it?
所以我只是不知道该怎么感受。我们应该非常不安他们正在做这件事，还是应该不安情况要求他们这样做但高兴他们正在做？
I think you should be upset that the situation got to this point, but glad that there is an actor, namely the US government, that is still in a position to do this. The US government still has the ability to borrow and because it still has the ability to borrow, it can provide support for the banking system and the broader financial system and prevent what otherwise could be even a catastrophic run.
我想你应该对情况发展到这种地步感到不安，但高兴有一个行动者，即美国政府，仍然处于能够做这件事的境地。美国政府仍然有能力借款，因为它仍然有能力借款，它可以为银行系统和更广泛的金融系统提供支持，防止可能发生的甚至是灾难性的挤兑。
Because in some of these other countries, the US government is right now in a position where they can borrow money essentially for free at very, very low interest rates, at 0.1%. That's the exact opposite of generally what happens when other crises happen in other countries, right? Their borrowing costs go way up.
因为在其他一些国家，美国政府现在处于这样一个境地，他们本质上可以以非常、非常低的利率，以0.1%的利率免费借到钱。这与一般在其他国家发生其他危机时的情况完全相反，对吧？他们的借款成本会直线上升。
Either they have to pay exorbitant interest rates to borrow in their own currency or they can only borrow in someone else's currency, which means that you're taking on even more risk.
要么他们必须支付昂贵的利率来以他们自己的货币借款，要么他们只能以别人的货币借款，这意味着你在承担更大的风险。
So is there a limit to how much money the US government can borrow? Like, if they have to borrow another $700 billion in a month, and another $700 billion in a month after that, can they do it?
所以美国政府能借多少钱有限制吗？就像，如果他们一个月内必须再借7000亿美元，再一个月后再借7000亿美元，他们能做到吗？
Possibly. In some sense it depends on how much anxiety and fear there is, because the more anxiety and fear there is, the more money is leaving the banking system, leaving money markets, and the more money that's going into treasury bonds. So the more fearful everybody else is, the easier it is for the US government to borrow.
可能。在某种意义上，这取决于有多少焦虑和恐惧，因为焦虑和恐惧越多，离开银行系统、离开货币市场的钱就越多，进入国债的钱也就越多。所以其他每个人越害怕，美国政府就越容易借钱。
In other words, people are saying, I don't want to put my money in stocks that are plunging or in bonds of companies that might go out of business or in any country that doesn't happen to have the most powerful economy on the earth. No. I want my money in the one safe place I can think to put it, US treasuries.
换句话说，人们说，我不想把我的钱投在暴跌的股票上，或者可能破产公司的债券上，或者任何碰巧没有地球上最强大经济体的国家里。不。我想要把我的钱放在我能想到的唯一安全的地方，美国国债。
And this is another way the US government is different from a typical business. The more it screws things up, the more it mismanages its own economy, the more people want to lend it money.
这是美国政府与普通企业不同的另一种方式。它把事情搞砸得越厉害，它对他自己经济的管理越糟糕，人们就越想借钱给它。
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show. He's also one of the people putting together NPR's daily Planet Money podcast. You can find that by Googling Planet Money or  going to the iTunes store.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制作者之一。他也是制作NPR每日《Planet Money》播客的人之一。你可以通过谷歌搜索“Planet Money”或前往iTunes商店找到它。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Thea Chaloner, Sam Hallgren, Seth Lind, and PJ Vote.
我们今天的节目由莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和我本人与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、戴安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·柯尼希（Sarah Koenig）、艾米·奥莱利（Amy O'Leary）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。艾德里安·马西奥韦茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。感谢西亚·查洛纳（Thea Chaloner）、萨姆·霍尔格伦（Sam Hallgren）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和PJ·沃特（PJ Vote）提供的制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or sign up for our free weekly podcast, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或注册我们的免费每周播客，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management over sight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia who I walked in on this week in his office.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，本周我在他的办公室里碰到他。
And he's laying in the middle of the carpet, rolling around and laying around.
而他却躺在地毯中间，滚来滚去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This America Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。